-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Michael Keaton.
This film
is incredibly powerful.
I think it covers a part
of the history of 9/11
that maybe a lot of us in the,
you know, aftermath of that
weren't really focused on,
which was the
Victims Compensation Fund.
It's based on a true story.
You play a real person.
How much of this
and how much did you know
about the person you were
playing before you took it on?
-Not nearly as much
as I thought I would.
By the way, I just want
to tell you, honestly,
all kidding aside, I really did
want to do it on your show,
specifically talk about
this movie,
'cause I know you get it.
Let's not, you know, go down
the road of being too serious
or sacrosanct or anything.
But thanks for doing this.
I had seen the script
a while back, you know.
And it was really well-written.
But we couldn't quite figure out
where the movie was.
So it went away and then
it kind of circled back.
And I reread it and I said,
"Man, this is something
that I have to do."
It means a lot to me
and everyone, actually,
all of us, not just New Yorkers,
but all of us.
And so we just proceeded.
And when you talk about
how much I knew, not much.
I mean, when I did
"The Founder," you think --
the story of Ray Kroc, you know,
who started McDonald's,
basically,
except the McDonald's brothers,
as an example,
started McDonald's.
I didn't even know
there were McDonald's brothers.
So I didn't know much at all.
And it's so complicated and
it's such an interesting story
that it was easy to do
as a documentary
but tough to make as a movie.
So we finally got it done,
and I'm proud of it,
and it means a lot to me.
And thanks for letting me
talk about it on the show.
It's really good.
I play Ken Feinberg,
who was assigned the task
of determining essentially
what a life is worth,
because there was
a Victims Compensation Fund
after the 9/11 attacks.
And Ken, pro bono,
wanted to take this on.
And once he got into it,
he realized how unbelievably
complex it was.
And so his arc and the movie arc
is you think you'll just go in
and handle this
on a legal level,
and then you realize, you know,
unless you don't have a pulse,
you know,
you're not a human being,
you have to be affected by it
emotionally.
So, sorry to be too serious,
but, you know,
we got to go there.
And I'm proud of it, and thanks
for letting me talk about it.
-No, you know, one of the things
I took away watching it is,
you know, this reminded that
when really awful things happen,
and certainly this last year,
for example,
it's been awful for a lot
of different people,
everybody feels it
a different way.
-Yeah.
-You know, so it's really hard
for the people in charge to,
like, talk about it --
They want to talk about it
and be like,
"Look, let's just
take the emotion out,
and I'll tell you the best way
to deal with it,"
and that's an impossible thing
for people to do.
And so it's a really good film,
you know,
not just as a piece of history,
but just the power of empathy
and how important it is,
when you're talking to people
who've gone through
something painful,
to try to understand
why they're feeling it.
-Yeah, and empathy's the word,
isn't it?
I mean, you know, it's clichéd.
And, you know, we all sound
like knee-jerk liberals
when we talk about it,
but that's what it
comes down to, you know.
You know, it's being empathetic
and also doing the right thing.
Yeah.
-It's a beautiful film.
Congratulations on it.
I'd be remiss if I didn't
take this opportunity.
Our Pittsburgh Steelers
are about to start the season.
How are you feeling?
-How are you feeling?
-I'm feeling good.
-Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm a little nervous.
I mean, 39 ain't young
if you're a quarterback,
but then you look
at some people.
I was gonna ask you about that
and see how you were feeling.
I'll check in.
I text you too much.
I'm starting to bug you, right?
-No, no, no.
Look, I'm always very excited
to get a text from you.
But I'm a little jealous.
I heard you have
Mike Tomlin's number,
the coach for
the Pittsburgh Steelers.
-Yeah, yeah.
Listen to this.
[ Laughing ] My kid and I --
My kid and I were at
the one in -- Where was it?
-Tampa?
-Somewhere in Florida.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Tampa,
when, you know,
Ben throws
that unbelievable pass
that Holmes catches
in the end zone, they win it.
-I was there, as well, but you
were sitting with Fallon.
-Yeah. That's right.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
Now I remember.
Wait. Give me a minute.
[ Laughter ]
That's so good.
-Don't remember it now.
-Anyway, listen to this.
We're leaving.
Sean and I go --
He knows me.
I can't stand, try to go.
This is unbelievable.
People are going crazy.
Someday I'll tell you
another story, by the way,
about Hank Williams Jr.
sitting in front of us.
But that's a whole other thing.
It's so great, I can't tell you.
Barely sitting in front of us.
"Sitting" in air quotes, okay?
Anyway, we leave.
I go, "Come on,
we got to beat traffic."
We go down, we get in the car,
we're driving out.
I text or e-mail or something
Mike Tomlin,
the coach of
the Pittsburgh Steelers,
thinking -- I'm just doing it.
He's never gonna --
They just won the Super Bowl.
He texts me back.
I'm going,
"Why would you bother --
You just won the Super Bowl.
Why would you take nine seconds
out of your life
to text me back?"
You know what we should do, man?
We'll do a show
from the Burgh someday.
We'll go down and get your pop.
-Burgh Week.
We'll do Burgh Week.
We'll get all of the --
the Mt. Rushmore
of Burgh people.
-I love that. Love that.
-Hey, thanks, man.
It's always just a joy
to see you.
Thanks so much for being here.
"Worth" begins streaming
on Netflix September 3rd.